it is a race to the finish line as we
work to meet president biden's fourth of
july vaccination goal
thanks for joining us here at six i'm
denise feldick good evening i'm brian
loftis several states announcing vaccine
incentive programs nevada now becoming
the latest today offering
a raffle to entice those who may still
be at this point hesitant
sasha loftus joining us from allegiance
stadium with more
this is just a really exciting
announcement for so many here in nevada
and state leaders hope it will really
push our vaccine numbers up
in the coming weeks nevada back states
the state's new vaccine incentive
program will offer 5
million dollars worth of cash and prices
to 2 000 eligible nevadans
who received at least one coveted shot
this includes tuition prizes for those
12 to 17
and various cash prizes for anyone 18
and over
there will also be a grand prize for one
lucky person of 1
million dollars the governor says this
is just really a great way to encourage
some who may be hesitant here in our
state to get their shots
people in nevada have just have more of
a hesitancy
and resistance to get vaccines and we
knew that going in
we fully well knew that going in other
states don't have that problem
they don't have some of the diversity in
other states that we have in nevada
and that's created some of the problem
in getting people vaccinated there's
more hesitancy
in some diverse groups so we're doing
everything we can to provide outreach
and get people vaccinated
vacs days begins july 8th and continues
through august 26th
winners were announced every thursday
and anyone who's had at least one shot
will automatically be entered this is
being funded through the federal
government and will not affect
taxpayer dollars now another note this
is a raffle
not a lottery since there are laws
against lotteries here in our state
we of course have more information on
our website eight news now dot com
reporting inside allegion stadium sasha
loftis 8 news now